welche karten hält putin in der hand die
ihn dazu gebracht haben die spannung in
osteuropa auf das niveau des kalten
krieges anzuheben die russischen
separatisten in der ost ukraine also
erkennen und ihn nun sogar seine truppen
ganz offiziell zur hilfe zu schicken was
sind russland stärken im aktuellen
konflikt um die ukraine und zu welchen
weiteren schritten kann moskau diese
stärken nutzen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ziel scheint klar zu sein putin will
russland die dazu politischer und
militärischer größe verhelfen den
russisch sowjetischen imperialismus
wiederbeleben in einem früheren radio
haben soll erklärt wie der einmarsch in
die ukraine zu einer falle werden könnte
von den usa konstruiert um russlands
entwicklung zu behindern wir haben sogar
davon erzählt wie sehr sich washington
darauf rollen könnte dass russische
truppen die ukrainische grenze
überschreiten er ist es jedoch klar dass
moskau eine ganz andere rechnung
aufgemacht hat das land hat sich in den
letzten zwei jahrzehnten stark verändert
und putins regierung fühlt sich heute
stärker denn je und für eine
ganzheitliche abschätzung der lage und
zukunft ist es unabdingbar einen genauen
blick auf die vier stärken zu werfen
jene vier trümpfe gilardino putin dazu
gebracht haben die letzte große
politische militärische krise auf dem
europäischen kontinent zu entfesseln aus
diesem grund haben wir dieses video
gedreht also aufgepasst
die entfesselte kraft
als putin am 31 dezember 1999 die
führung der russischen föderation
übernahmen die streitkräfte des landes
nicht gerade in bester zu dieser zeit
war die russische armee kaum mehr als
ein veraltetes verrostetes gebildet
dessen fähigkeiten tag für tag ab
rüttelten die einst mächtige sowjetische
atom u boot flotte kämpfte um ihr
überleben die luftwaffe war mit ihrem
katastrophalen zustand konfrontiert die
soldaten fehlt es an der grundlegenden
ausrüstung und sowohl sie als auch die
für sie zuständigen offizier erlebten
heruntergekommen und baufälligen
unterkünften erschwerend kam hinzu dass
der krieg in tschetschenien zu einem
nicht enden wollenden alptraum geworden
war sagen wir einfach mal dass damals
die moral genau wie die gehälter beim
militär am absoluten tiefpunkt
angekommen waren
[Musik]
wladimir putin versuchte zwar sofort das
ruder herumzureißen hatte zunächst aber
auch kein glückliches händchen erst 2008
kam es zu einem echten wendepunkt in
diesem jahr trifft die russische armee
georgien an ein kleines land im kaukasus
und wisst ihr was trotz der enormen
überlegenheit der streitkräfte wurden
die unzulänglichkeiten der russischen
armee sofort offenbar es traten alle
möglichen probleme auf die bodentruppen
zum beispiel verfügten über keine
direkten kommunikationsmittel mit der
luftwaffe was gleich mehrfach zu
schweren verlusten durch eigenen
beschuss führte panzer und
transportfahrzeuge litten unter
zahlreichen mechanischen ausfällen die
koordination zwischen den verschiedenen
militärkommando es war praktisch nicht
vorhanden es gab keine präzisionswaffen
und die truppen bereitschaft war
katastrophal
[Musik]
der georgien krieg war der wichtigste
wendepunkt für russland von diesem
moment an macht la die mir putin die
militärreform zu einer nationalen
priorität seiner meinung nach muster
russlands militär komplett neu aufbauen
und modernisieren und ihr wisst ja
wladimir wladimirowitsch ist ein mann
der tat
seit 2008 hat sich die situation des
russischen militärs vollkommen verändert
putin hat einen gewaltigen investition
und erneuerungsprozess der streitkräfte
vorangetrieben heute ist die russische
armee kleiner aber viel einsatzfähiger
und moderner ihre einheiten haben eine
bessere ausrüstung die
einsatzmöglichkeiten haben sich
vervielfacht die luftwaffe hat hunderte
neuer flugzeuge oder die marine setzte
neue atom u boote der klasse 1
man kann sagen dass der wandel in
praktisch allen bereichen geradezu
atemberaubend war möchtet ihr ein
konkretes beispiel sehen nun ohne lange
suchen zu müssen fallen sofort die t 72
panzer ins auge die entlang der
ukrainischen grenze stationiert wurden
diese panzer sind mit einem neuen
wärmebild system ausgestattet mit dem
sie auch nachts eingesetzt werden können
hinzu komme die calida marschflugkörper
die auf schiffen und u booten im
schwarzen meer stationiert sind sowie
die mobilen ballistischen iskander
raketen in landwirt grenze stationiert
wurden und die ziele in so gut wie der
gesamten ukraine zerstören können
[Musik]
und das sind nur ein paar beispiele denn
die wahrheit ist dass sich die russische
streitkräfte radikal verändert haben
seit wladimir putin an die macht kamen
das hat es dem kreml ermöglicht eine
vielzahl von einsätzen im ausland zu
führen und zwar mit beträchtlichen
erfolg denkt zum beispiel an die
operation auf der krim und ist syrien
sowie die blitz einsätze nahm wenigen
und kasachstan tatsächlich hat russland
all dieser einsätze geschickt genutzt um
seine strategien zu verfeinern und
einsatz und kommt erfahrung zu sammeln
dies ist ein entscheidender faktor bei
der durchführung von militäroperationen
es handelt sich sozusagen um real life
manöver deren wert gar nicht hoch genug
eingeschätzt werden kann so haben wir
auch dem russischen
verteidigungsminister sergej schoigu
alle kommandeure der bodentruppen 92
prozent der piloten der luftwaffe und 62
prozent der marineeinheiten reale
schlachtfeld erfahrung natürlich leidet
das russische militär immer noch unter
vielen einschränkungen wie zum beispiel
beschränkten zugang zu modernster
technologie oder den rückhalt einer
starken wirtschaft die seine entwicklung
finanziert und im ernstfall ausreichend
nachschub und versorgung sicherstellen
wird in einer reinen materialschlacht
wäre russland gegen dann wieder nato
oder china das ich zb das rohstoff
partizipiere unter den nagel reißen
könnte hoffnungslos unterlegen trotzdem
ist es klar dass die situation heute
eine ganz andere ist als im jahr 2000
[Applaus]
putins erste große stärke in der ukraine
krise besteht also gerade darin damit
rechnen zu können dass die russische
armee in der lage ist sauber und schnell
einzugreifen dabei handelt es sich nicht
nur um eine bedeutende
machtdemonstration sondern versetzt
russland in die lage sehr schnell in die
nächste phase dieses politisch
militärischen konflikts einzutreten es
liegt auf der hand dass sich in
bereitschaft befindende streitkräfte die
zahl der optionen um die
verhandlungsmacht deutlich erhöhen diese
stärke russlands ist die
offensichtlichste sie ist jedoch bei
weitem nicht die einzige und was da
viele überraschend klingen wird auch
nicht die wichtigste auf die sich putin
verlässt um seinen willen durchzusetzen
also seid ihr auch seine anderen trümpfe
gespannt wollt ihr wissen warum sich
putin all das erlauben kann was er sich
erlaubt welche als er noch im ärmel und
welche er schon verspielt hat keine
angst wir werden sie euch bis ins letzte
detail vorstellen
[Musik]
die strategie der festung russland
die wirtschafts- und finanzsanktionen
mit denen die usa und die eu russland
nach der besetzung der krim bestraft
haben haben der russischen wirtschaft
einen schweren schlag versetzt die wir
bereits in einem früheren video
berichtet haben führten die sanktionen
in russland zu einem rückgang des
verfügbaren einkommens des
wirtschaftswachstums unter ausländischen
investitionen und wieder einmal lauter
westen nach dem einfall russlands auf
ukrainisches territorium weiterer und
noch viel härtere sanktionen angekündigt
sanktionen von denen die russische
regierung jedoch hofft dass sie zu
beginn der zeit verdaut werden um dies
zu erreichen treffen die russen seit
2004 vorbereitungen im rahmen einer
strategie eines plans der allgemein als
festung russland bekannt geworden ist
[Musik]
denn im jahr 2014 hat die russische
regierung verstanden dass internationale
sanktionen nicht nur der russischen
wirtschaft sondern auch der eigenen
entscheidungs und handlungsfähigkeit
enormen schaden zufügen können denn ohne
ausreichende ressourcen ist es sehr
schwierig eine effektive aussenpolitik
zu betreiben gerade deshalb erkannte der
kreml dass die wirtschaft darauf
vorbereitet werden muss den neuen
sanktionen so gut wie möglich zu
widerstehen es ging darum die gesamte
russische wirtschaft abzuhärten immun
gegen sanktionen zu machen und die
ersten schritte waren ausgleich der
öffentlichen haushalte erhöhung der
devisenreserven und verringerung der
abhängigkeit vom dollar
diese grundlegenden zielen der
wirtschaftspolitik des riesigen landes
welches so schnell wie möglich auch
umgesetzt wurden zu den kreml hat es
oberste priorität die regierung darauf
vorzubereiten den auswirkungen starker
internationaler sanktionen notfalls
standhalten zu können ohne ihre
handlungsfähigkeit zumindest kurzfristig
einzuschränken und eines kann ich euch
sagen die umsetzung dieser grundlegenden
ziele ist putin bravourös gelungen so
hat der russische regierung in den
letzten jahren ihre öffentlichen
haushalte ausgeglichen und eine riesige
devisenreserven in höhe von mehr als 600
milliarden dollar aufgebaut während es
ihr gleichzeitig auch gelangt ihre
ausnahmestellung stark herunterzufahren
schauen sie einfach mal an
die idee dahinter ist dass die russische
regierung im fall einer eskalation des
konflikts mit den usa und der eu diese
riesigen geldreserven als rettungsanker
nutzen kann moskau rechnet auch mit
steigenden öl und gaspreisen um diese
devisenreserven in den nächsten jahren
weiter zu erhöhen
russland ist viel besser auf die
sanktionen vorbereitet als 2014
zumindest was die makro indikatoren
angeht der staatliche sektor ist in
guter verfassung und das finanzielle
polster ist groß natalia lawrowa
chefvolkswirt der bcs financial group in
moskau darüber hinaus hat russland sein
engagement gegenüber dem dollar
reduziert und die präsenz anderer
währungen wie des euro oder single one
sowohl in seinen devisenreserven als
auch vor allem in seinen eigenen
handelsbeziehungen erhöht
[Musik]
und ja wie wir euch in einem früheren
video auf diese politik erklärt haben
könnten internationale sanktionen der
russischen wirtschaft mittel und
langfristig enormen schaden zufügen
daran gibt es kaum zweifel
die mittel- und langfristigen
auswirkungen russland in eine
finanzielle und wirtschaftliche
aufzutreiben sowie die kosten für die
bürger werden enorm das potenzielle
wachstum wird ohne interaktion mit der
welt viel geringer sein elena bakuba
stellvertretende chefökonomen des
international institute of finance und
aus diesem grund werden viele von euch
vielleicht einwenden dass die
vorgenannten zungen auf den ersten blick
viel geld zu sein scheinen wir aber
bedenken müssten dass wir über ein land
mit einer bevölkerung von mehr als 140
millionen menschen sprechen und wenn es
hart auf hart käme könnten die reserven
im laufe der zeit aufgezehrt werden das
russische volk würde dabei aber wir
reden hier nicht über das demokratische
frei ist und transparenteste land der
welt für den kreml ist die wichtigste
frage nicht ob die sanktionen dem
lebensstandard der bevölkerung schaden
werden das ist in gewisser weise die
geringste sorge wichtig ist nur ob das
regime diesen bedingungen standhalten
kann ohne in ihrer arbeit und ihrem
einfluss möglichkeiten eingeschränkt zu
werden in gewisser weise sollen nicht
nur die wirtschaft sondern auch die
bevölkerung langfristig abgehärtet und
daran gewöhnt werden sich für die
ambitionen der herrschenden eliten
welche ihre eigenen kinder selbst lieber
ins westliche ausland schicken
aufzuopfern es ist eine durchhalten bis
zum endsieg strategie durch die festung
russland hofft der kreml sich bis dahin
ein ausreichend handlungsspielraum
verschaffen zu können wie auch immer
seine entscheidung letztendlich
ausfallen mögen gleichzeitig hofft er
die europäischen regierungen davon
überzeugen zu können eine eher lauwarme
position einzunehmen vor allem wenn die
intervention in der ukraine begrenzt ist
oder eben scheibchenweise als eine art
salamitaktik kommt denn die ja so zuerst
versorge ich ein paar gewaltbereite
sympathisanten jenseits der grenze mit
waffen und militärischer ausbildung dann
verstärke ich sie noch mit soldaten
meine eigene armee aber schön verdeckt
und hinterhältig in unmarkierten
uniformen ich lasse diese menschen dann
putzen und die unabhängigkeit des
besetzten gebietes erklären ein paar
jahre lang bringe ich verdeckt noch mehr
soldaten und waffen dorthin und
verteidige das gebiet gegen
rückeroberung versuche und schließlich
erkläre ich das besetzte gebiet zu
meinem und schickem eine reguläre armeen
das ganze karriere ich mit einem schönen
zuckerguss aus opfer mythen und
halbwahrheiten und meine fans bei laune
zu halten ja genauso geht eben jemand
vor der in seiner pa den furchtlosen
macho markiert dann aber aus angst vor
der eher harmlosen omikron variante des
corona virus einen sieben meter langen
monster tisch zwischen sich und seinen
gästen braucht oder war das auch nur
wieder irgendein abstruser psycho trick
wie dem auch sei parallel führt den jahr
an der propagandafront auf jeden fall
eine geliebte zermürbungstaktik so wurde
versucht die warnung der amerikaner vor
einer russischen invasion ist
lächerliche zu ziehen natürlich haben
sie ihm dafür selbst die besten daten in
die hände gespielt denn was des
informationskampagnen zur rechtfertigung
militärische interventionen angeht haben
die usa selbst eine sehr lange und
unrühmliche tradition von tonkin
zwischenfall bei dem die regierung des
demokratischen präsidenten lyndon
johnson kids teens falschinformation
notierte um ihren eintritt in den
antrieb zu legitimieren bis zu den
erfundenen beweisen über die angeblichen
massenvernichtungswaffen in rath mit
denen die regierung der republikaner
george hw bush und dick cheney die
weltöffentlichkeit an der nase
herumführte um ihren muffins
organisierten irakkrieg loszutreten denn
wie heißt es so schön wer einmal lügt
dem glaubt man nicht und genau dies
versucht die propaganda des kreml
maximal auszunutzen auch wenn sie selbst
verfügen nur so strotzt
manchmal kommt ein geopolitik schon wie
ein gigantischer forschungsreport vor
bei dem es jedoch traurigerweise gar
nicht darum geht wer die intelligenteste
verschwörung mehr sind sondern wer mit
der blödesten verschwörung die
jeweiligen meinungs- babbels am besten
abstumpft aber die frage ist nun wer
führt im augenblick in diesem
propagandakrieg nun seine karten die usa
würden des informationen über einen
russischen einmarsch vorbereiten hat
putin bereits verspielt er konzentriert
sich nun aber auf die verfestigung eines
neuen tiefs dass die ukraine als staat
eigentlich keine historische
legitimation besitzt ein konstrukt
lenins ist eine ausscheidung russlands
und auch sonst einfach nur ein feld sei
deswegen sollte man sie lieber auf
andere staaten aufteilen zu denen ihre
gebiete irgendwann früher gehört haben
der osten würde natürlich bei russland
zu fallen das ist völkerrechtlich
natürlich totaler quatsch ähnlich könnte
man auch die existenz der schweiz
infrage stellen die von belarus und
natürlich auch die der russischen
föderation selbst putin kann wirklich
nur hoffen dass ihn im kaukasus der
mongolei turkmenistan ja deutschland
niemand gehört hat oder zumindest
niemand ernst nimmt über kaliningrad das
ehemalige königsberg haben schon ein
schönes video gedreht aber im ernst kann
er mit diesem geschichtsrevisionistische
narrativ erfolg haben nun das ist gar
nicht mal auszuschließen er weiß dass
man eine lüge nur mit ein paar
halbwahrheiten sanieren und dann oft
genug wiederholen muss bis sie genügend
dummköpfe glauben ihm ist es schließlich
auch gelungen die legende von bruch
eines angeblichen versprechens die nato
würde keine neuen mitglieder in austin
aufnehmen fest zu etablieren
diesen mythos haben wir bereits im
vorherigen video dieser reihe entlarvt
ihr könnt es euch über das symbol oben
rechts oder über den link in der
beschreibung ansehen wie gut ist
propaganda auch im westen greift
eigentlich von daran dass diese legende
überall ständig wiedergegeben wird oft
und ihre legitimität auch einen ansatz
zu hinterfragen eine andere ganz reale
vertragsverletzung moskaus in den medien
jedoch kaum thematisiert wird der bruch
des budapester memorandums
darin verpflichteten sich nämlich die
usa großbritannien und russland die
unabhängigkeit und die existierenden
grenzen der ukraine zu respektieren im
gegenzug trat die ukraine den
atomwaffensperrvertrag bei ähnlichem
morgana unterzeichneten am gleichen tag
übrigens auch die ehemaligen
sowjetrepubliken weißrussland und
kasachstan das heißt die ukraine gab
damals 1994 ein ganz wichtiges pfund aus
der hand ihren status als atommacht weil
sie sich oft die garantie russlands
verließ ihre territoriale integrität
nicht zu verletzen und wir sprechen hier
nicht über eine kleinigkeit mit einem
atomar bewaffneten land gehen alle ganz
anders um die ukraine entschied sich
aber ihre atombomben gegen einen wechsel
papier aus moskaus so tauschen aber sie
wäre ja nicht das erste land das sich
auf das wort des kreml verließ und sich
darüber wunderte dass sich die aus dem
osten an rhythmen invasionstruppen
plötzlich nicht mehr so gut an ihre
abmachungen erinnern konnten tja warum
nur dachten die ukraine ihn würde es
anders ergehen als den tschechen nächste
wagen den ungarn und vielen anderen
opfern des russischen liberalismus die
auch alle von friedenstruppen beglückt
wurden nun ist es aber ebenso wie es ist
die ukraine hat keine atomwaffen mehr
was im grunde natürlich sehr
begrüßenswert ist russland hat sein
versprechen gebrochen in der
öffentlichkeit hat sich jedoch dagegen
mythos etabliert ist wer die nato
gewesen die er angeblich ist versprechen
gebrochen hätte tja ungerecht ist die
welt und wladimir putin ist eben ein
meister darin ungerechtigkeiten für sich
auszunutzen und dann ja dann im
optimalen augenblick zuzuschlagen aber
was kommt jetzt schneidet er sich nicht
ins eigene hat er trümpfe in der hand
mit denen er den voll auf seinen
bisherigen aktionen ausstechen kann ja
die hat er zum beispiel das was man als
gegen sanktionen bezeichnet könnte also
aufgepasst
[Musik]
die frostige botschaft muss raus an
europa
es wird wohl niemanden überraschen wenn
ich sage dass russland ein sehr
wichtiger exporteur von rohstoffen die
erdgas jüngere aluminium stahl platin
gold und nickel und vielen anderen
wertvollen ressourcen ist
wir sprechen über lieferungen die in
vielen fällen für europäische
unternehmen und volkswirtschaften
unerlässlich sind das ist zum beispiel
beim erdgas der fall die europäische
union importiert mehr als 40 prozent ist
von ihr verbrauchten gases aus russland
daraus folgt dass sanktionen wenn sie zu
aggressiv ausfallen den zugang der
europäischen volkswirtschaften zu all
diesen rohstoffen wie zb erdgas
beeinträchtigen könnten einige länder
die österreich polen und deutschland
stark und erdgas abhängig
[Musik]
vor allem deutschland das sich durch den
überhasteten atomausstieg und
gleichzeitigen kohleausstieg ganz
absichtlich und mutwillig in hochgradig
abhängigkeit von russischem erdgas
begeben hat und passt auf den russisches
erdgas zu ersetzen ist keine leichte
aufgabe erstens weil verflüssigtes
erdgas lng dass die einzige wirkliche
alternative wäre viel zu teuer ist und
zweitens weil die förderländer heute
keine große gewinnspannen haben europa
müsste gas aus den asiatischen
volkswirtschaften beziehen und dafür
tief in die tasche greifen
wohlstandsverlust für alle bürger und
dann absturz der wettbewerbsfähigkeit
der europäischen industrie und
landwirtschaft wären die folge wir
sprechen hier nicht nur überfrierende
europäer im winter sondern auch
überlebensmittel mangel denn erdgas ist
ein wichtiges vorprodukt für kunstdünger
dessen preise 3 ist auch so schon wegen
gestörter lieferketten in folge der
korona lockerungspolitik explodiert sind
viele landwirte werden dieses jahr ihren
einsatz von christina daher drastisch
zurückfahren die konsequenzen daraus
wären die europäer wohl erst im herbst
diesen jahres zu spüren bekommen
lebensmittelpreise die durch die decke
gehen und leere supermarktregale dieses
ganze szenario wirkt natürlich extrem
abschreckend sanktionen könnten die
handelsbeziehungen erschweren während
russland als druckmittel die lieferung
vieler rohstoffe dozieren oder sogar
aussetzen könnte so ist moskau davon
überzeugt dass die großen regierungen
der europäischen union am ende alles tun
werden um die dinge auch bei sich nicht
vollkommen aus dem ruder laufen zu
lassen und das heißt viel weniger
sanktionen verhängen als washington es
gerne hätte das gilt vor allem für den
fall dass sie mit einer schrittweisen
salami invasion konfrontiert sein werden
ja olaf scholz hat zwar vorerst die
inbetriebnahme der nostrum 23 plan
gestoppt aber wie wir wissen geht es ja
nur um eine zertifizierung und papier
ist geduldig die pipeline ist fertig
gebaut sie ist physisch vorhanden und
könnten wenn sich die wogen geglättet
haben oder wird darauf mal wirklich groß
ist jederzeit in betrieb genommen werden
ihr denkt ich würde übertreiben nun
nehmt euch in acht denn es gibt einen
wichtigen präzedenzfall
[Musik]
2018 verhängten die usa sanktionen gegen
roßtal das führende russische
aluminiumunternehmen wegen seiner
verbindungen zu oleg deripaska einem
kreml nahen oligarchen die sanktionen
ließen die preise um 30 prozent in die
höhe schnellen bestraften alle arten von
industrien von automobilherstellern bis
zum herstellern von soft bringt der
druck war so groß dass washington nur
ein paar monate später wieder beschloss
die sanktionen aufzuheben und die lage
sieht nun mal so aus dass der russische
energieriese gazprom die gaslieferungen
nach europa bereits im jahr 2021
gedrosselt hat was die reserven
verringert und die preise in die höhe
getrieben hat und das alles hat dazu
beigetragen dass sich nach schätzungen
von jp morgan die energierechnung europa
seit 2009 verdoppelt hat und wir reden
hier nicht über ein paar euro sondern
von mehrausgaben von über 500 milliarden
dollar ja das hast du richtig gehört
bereits jetzt 500 milliarden eine halbe
million jährlich moskau wendet hier ganz
klar die spieltheorie an denn einerseits
wissen sie dass sie mittel und
langfristig darauf angewiesen sind dass
europa weiterhin ihre rohstoffe abnimmt
und sie wissen dass eine reduzierung
oder aussetzung belieferungen
langfristig zu großen verlusten führen
könnte kurzfristig könnten die dinge
jedoch ganz anders aussehen die enorme
abhängigkeit der europäischen
volkswirtschaften von russischen
lieferungen ist eindruck faktor den
moskau zu nutzen hofft oder zumindest zu
nutzen oft um einen diplomatischen
triumph zu erringen aber wir sind noch
nicht fertig denn putin hat noch eine
vierte karte mit und die hat es in sich
[Musik]
der rote drache grund zur rettung
historisch betrachtet haben sich
russland bzw die russisch dominierte
street union und china noch nie gut
verstanden im gegenteil ihrer
beziehungen waren eigentlich schrecklich
in den letzten jahren jedoch hat sich
die situation ziemlich verändert wir
haben über dieses thema bereits vor
einiger zeit schon mehrere ausführliche
videos gedreht die ich euch in der
beschreibung verlinken werde fakt ist
nur wenige stars aber heute haben so
viele ted bildchen gesammelt wie
wladimir putin und jean ping um euch
eine vorstellung von ihrer wertschätzung
füreinander zu geben die beiden
politischen führer haben sich fast 40
mal gegenüber gesessen und kein einziges
mal hatten sie dabei einen sieben meter
langen monster tisch zwischen sich aber
hier geht es um etwas was noch viel
wichtiger ist als pures symbolpolitik
demnächst chinesische angaben betrug das
handelsvolumen zwischen beiden ländern
im jahr 2021 über
145 milliarden us dollar das heißt der
asiatische riese ist schon jetzt
russlands wichtigster handelspartner und
bis 2024 so der bilaterale handel 200
milliarden dollar übersteigen
[Musik]
wenn es also mit dem westen preislich
wird glaubt moskau dass die chinesische
wirtschaft soll die riesige mengen an
devisen hält und rohstoffe verschlingt
als gäbe es kein morgen für russland ein
echter retter sein könnte zumindest wenn
es darum geht den worst case zu
vermeiden ich denke putin hat
wahrscheinlich von ski die zusicherung
erhalten dass china im fall einer krise
in der ukraine und der verhängung von
sanktionen gegen russland an der seite
russlands stehen wird archäologie
professor für internationale beziehungen
an der far eastern university das alles
bringt natürlich zwei probleme mäßig zum
einen kann china die westlichen
volkswirtschaften nicht vollständig
ersetzen wirtschaftlich gesehen wäre
eine russland mit weniger westen und
mehr china viel viel schwächer auf der
anderen seite würde es die russische
wirtschaft in eine große abhängigkeit
von china führen welche die chinesen wie
in allen anderen fällen auch schamlos
ausnutzen würden um glaubt der moskau
ist sich der tatsache dass peking auf
nichts anderes aus ist überaus bewusst
der kreml mag wenig vertrauen in die
amerikaner haben aber glaubt nicht eine
sekunde daran dass er den chinesen auch
nur ein haar bereit weiter trauen würde
im gegenteil er weiß dass dicken es
langfristig aus sibirien und die dort
lagernden unermesslichen
rohstoffvorkommen abgesehen hat china
verfügt über eine gigantische land armee
gegen welches sibirien nur schwer zu
halten wäre von peking jakutsk ist es
nur halb so weit wie von moskau aus
[Applaus]
langfristig gesehen muss der kreml also
auch hier einen balance akt von führen
darauf achten nicht zu sehr auf eine
seite zu kippen zu diesem zeitpunkt
allerdings kann er sich darauf verlassen
dass die drohung die beziehungen
zwischen china und russland zu stärken
also weitere abschreckung wirkt denn
eine bindung der westlichen kräfte im
europäischen konflikt mit russland
könnte den chinesen einen strategischen
moment verschaffen und sie mit einer
invasion teil waren es zu übertölpeln
die frage ist natürlich welches teil
guest für welchen schritt in welcher
intensität das richtige das aber ist ein
sehr komplexes thema das wir in einem
separaten video analysieren werden
vergesst also gedicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren und auch das glöckchen zur
aktivierung und keines unserer
spannenden videos mehr zu verpassen ich
danke euch zurzeit bereiten russland und
china ja so einiges vor um sich
gegenüber den wespen sanktions test zu
machen sie planen ein gemeinsames vom
rest der welt abgekoppelt finanzsystem
und internet die frage ist jedoch wie
effizient und innovativ können derartige
inseln der abgekoppelten sein fallen sie
im wettlauf um qualität und quantität
mit der zeit nicht er mehr und mehr
zurück und mittlerweile hat russland
seine gasexporte nach china über die
bestehende pipeline auf 16 5 milliarden
kubikmeter verdreifacht und mit peking
einen 30 jahres vertrag über
gaslieferungen unterzeichnet die große
überraschung in euro abgerechnet werden
soll
dazu soll eine ganz neue gas- pipeline
gebaut wäre so dass lieferungen bis 2025
noch mal mehr als verdoppelt werden
sollen auf etwa 38 milliarden kubikmeter
pro jahr allerdings wenn man dies mit
den liefermengen nach europa in bezug
setzt wird das ganze eher wie ein
tropfen auf den heißen stein allein
ostring 2 ist oft 55 milliarden
kubikmeter pro jahr ausgelegt und
insgesamt kaufte europa den größten
jährlich zwischen 185 und 200 milliarden
kubikmeter erdgas ab das ist mehr als
fünfmal so viel wie die menge die russen
und ab 2025 nach china zu liefern hofft
außerdem sind solche pipelines im
kriegsfall sowieso nicht viel wert und
können als statische und agile ziele
durch marschflugkörper sehr leicht
unterbrochen werden und das problem für
russland ist dass die usa dieses mal
beschlossen haben und ganz klar ihre
handlungsfähigkeit zu demonstrieren die
wahrheit ist nämlich dass putins karten
obwohl sie alle für ihn wichtig sind
nicht so stark sind vor allem weil
russland und europa in diesem spiel viel
zu verlieren und sehr wenig zu gewinnen
haben das ist das genaue gegenteil der
position der usa trotzdem gibt es keinen
zweifel an der tatsache dass russland
heute viel besser darauf vorbereitet ist
der politischen offensive des westens zu
widerstehen als bis das vor 10 oder 15
jahren war aber auf lange sicht können
die sanktionen die suche nach
alternativen zu russischen
energielieferungen und der militärische
wettlauf entlang der europäischen
grenzen dem land einen schweren schlag
versetzen
wozu also das alles nun im grunde
genommen für ziemlich wenig die krim
marke wegen des schwarzmeerhafen es noch
ein wichtiges strategisches ziel gewesen
sein aber die verwüsteten regionen im
don bastelt wirtschaftlich und
militärisch ziemlich wertlos sie werden
russland strategisch nicht stärken
sondern eher schwächen und das
schlechteste preis leistungsverhältnis
erzielt in diesem ganzen spiel natürlich
das russische volk durch die bisherige
abkoppelung seiner volkswirtschaft hat
es bereits fast ein ganzes jahrzehnt
entwicklung und des wohlstands geopfert
wo könnte russland heute stehen hätte es
sich nicht 2014 dafür entschieden die
territoriale integrität der ukraine zu
verletzen im politischen sinne ist diese
frage jedoch erst sekundär denn für
putin steht natürlich die frage im
vordergrund wo würde ich stehe wäre ich
noch an der macht wenn ich die
nationalistische klaviatur etwas sanfter
angeschlagen hätte schließlich geht es
darum dieses lied so lange wie möglich
zu spielen über seine separatisten im
sonntaz kann er schön gemütlich einen
stellvertreterkrieg führen dessen
intensität er nach lust und laune
bestimmt wichtig dabei ist dass es nicht
nur ein hin und her handelt welches die
unsicherheit bei der gegenseite
maximiert mal ist hohe mann ist
gesprächsbereit dass frieden wird
beschworen mal wird eine kleine false
flag aktion veranstaltet
un-friedenstruppen entsenden und wieder
für eine eskalation der spannungen zu
sorgen mal ein paar ukraine erschossen
oder verhaftet mal die ganze
staatlichkeit der ukraine in frage
gestellt und mal wird auch eine aus
amsterdam kommenden passagiermaschine
abgeschossen kollateralschäden eben für
die putin jede verantwortung von sich
weist klar die lorbeeren nimmt er gerne
entgegen aber diese hässlichen dinge
nein nein daran ist er doch nicht selber
schuld klar dabei ist der weg ist sein
ziel und besteht aus permanente unruhe
und instabilität für die ukraine die so
schritt für schritt zurückgedrängt und
verwittert es ist das klassische
vorgehen eines psychopathen der sein
opfer nicht selbst umbringen sondern
eher in den selbstmord treiben will
[Musik]
denn wenn putin etwas gelernt hat dann
das ist genau diese handlungsweise ist
welche in die europäer am ehesten
durchgehen lassen warum das risiko einer
groß angelegten invasion eingehen wenn
man schrittweise doch besser ein sein
ziel kommt dazu passt schließlich auch
sein letzter schritt die von der ukraine
abtrünnigen regionen in der bastion ganz
offiziell anzuerkennen und seine truppen
dorthin zu entsenden es ist wieder
nichts halbes und nichts ganzes er
demonstriert damit seinen anhängern dass
er etwas tut aber es ist nicht der
befürchtete große feldzug die bedeutung
eines offiziellen einmarsches ist eher
symbolischer der gebiete faktisch
sowieso schon seit 2010 von russland
kontrolliert werden der seit dem
bestehen des status quo wird geht es nur
noch formalisiert
die schlüsselfrage dabei ist jedoch in
welchen grenzen erkennt ausland diese
neuen volksrepublik als die ursprünglich
ihre unabhängigkeit folgt erklärten
kontrollierten sie die gesamtfläche der
region donetsk und lugansk und wurden
erst später von der ukrainischen armee
zurückgedrängt in ihren verfassungen
wird klar festgelegt dass das offizielle
staatsgebiet durch die grenzen bestimmt
werde die zum zeitpunkt der ausrufung
bestanden gemeint sind also die
vollständigen verwaltungsgrenzen beider
regionen die heute zu zwei dritteln
wieder von der ukraine kontrolliert
werden und genau hier könnte putin
wieder ansetzen und weiteres vordringen
in die ukraine zu rechtfertigen und eine
langfriststrategie des schreckens ohne
ende fortzusetzen über dieses kino
spielt hier im donbass versuchte er ja
schon die ganze zeit die kleine zu
unterwandern russlands internationale
präsenz zu stärken eine warnung an seine
nachbarländer zu setzen und die nato zu
spalten und man muss feststellen dass
alles ist ihnen durch den jetzigen
schritt nicht gelungen
[Musik]
die traurige wahrheit ist wahr dass
putin angesichts der anfänglichen
reaktion von ländern wie frankreich und
deutschland die sich für eine versöhnung
aussprachen und sich sogar von
washington distanzierten vielleicht
nicht weit davon entfernt war seinen
willen durchzusetzen
dieses zu gelangen war nicht nur
bedauerlich sondern eigentlich
unverantwortlich eine fortsetzung der
laissez faire politik die putin er
ermutigt hat immer weiter so gehen
könnte sein letzter schritt also nun
endlich den usa jene mittel in die hand
geben ein ende des schreckens
herbeizuführen wie lange kann putin
diese krise jetzt noch im stadium eines
fortschreitenden schwelbrand halten weil
hier die ukraine ja so schwer belastet
es muss schließlich eine große
streikmacht unterhalten die es sich
eigentlich gar nicht leisten kann
ausländische investoren halten sich von
der ukraine stellen weil sie angst vor
der bevorstehenden invasion haben müssen
die ukraine selbst ziehen auch ins
ausland und der kriegsgefahr und auch
der durchgeführten armut zu entgehen was
nun zu einer weiteren stabilisierung der
wirtschaft führt protein wollte mit
diesem teufelskreis dieser psychischen
und wirtschaftlichen zermürbungstaktik
an sein ziel ohne mit seinen truppen in
kiew einmarschieren zu müssen er will
der ukraine demonstrieren dass es doch
eigentlich in ihrem eigenen interesse
sei eine kolonie moskaus zu sein und das
große teile von ihr sowieso heim ins
reich gehören viele spricht daher dafür
dass die anerkennung der volksrepublik
nur ein politischer zwischenschritt in
seinem großen plan ist natürlich er sich
und russland damit bei den meisten
ukrainer noch verhasster gemacht als du
vor mittlerweile wählen 80 prozent der
ukrainer pro europäisch oder ukrainische
nationalistisch ein machtwechsel
zugunsten moskaus auf demokratischem weg
ist also ausgeschlossen demokratie und
die einfachen menschen in der ukraine
sind jedoch sowieso das letzte was den
kalkulierenden ex kgb oberst
interessiert für ihn ist das ganze ein
next level macht der krieg ein
revierkampf der euphemistisch als
oligarchen bezeichneten mafiabosse die
über russland und auch über die ukraine
herrschen die jeweiligen
volkswirtschaften kontrollieren und ihre
ressourcen für sich ab sofort den hut in
russland alle seine widersacher
eliminiert und ist zum uneingeschränkten
super über paten aufgestiegen
[Musik]
und er erhebt diesen anspruch auf seine
nachbarländer wie zb kasachstan und die
eigentliche frage ist nur wie weiter auf
dieser ebene in der ukraine
von seinem ziel noch entfernt ist ist
ist nicht nur eine frage der zeit bis
ihnen die ukrainische kabus wieder die
hand küssen bis sie erkennen dass sie
ihr widerstand gegen das teilen ihrer
profite mit putin sie mehr kostet als er
ihn einbringt oder kommt ihr amico
americano dessen sie ja auch schon mal
auf den lohnlisten hatten doch noch mit
einem unerwarteten schachzug um die ecke
ihr seht schon wir haben es hier mit um
ein spiel auf vielen verschiedenen
ebenen zu tun das militär die wirtschaft
dass russische und das ukrainische volk
europa und china die usa und die vor
ideologischen ebene auch jeder dieser
ebenen hält putin bestimmte trümpfe in
der hand mal größere mal kleinere manche
hat er gerade gewonnen manche verloren
deswegen werden wir aufgrund der
rasanten entwicklung noch diese woche
ein video heraus bringen indem wir die
auswirkungen der ersten
militärintervention russland seit der
invasion der krim und die schaffung
zweier neuer republiken in europa
genauer auseinander nehmen werden und
bis dahin seid ihr erst mal an der reihe
glaubt ihr dass punkt in seine position
und seine langfristige strategie eher
gestärkt oder geschwächt hat wird er
jetzt weitergehen wie sollte die nato
länder reagieren glaubt ihr dass rüsten
und wirklich mehr erreichen kann als es
jetzt schon erreicht hat und wenn ja auf
welchem weg wie immer freuen wir uns auf
eure interessanten und zahlreichen
kommentare ich hoffe also dass euch
dieses video gefallen hat falls ja gibt
uns mit einem like teilt es mit euren
freunden und vergesst nicht das abo mit
glöckchen und keines unserer videos
müssen verpassen natürlich freuen wir
uns auch jederzeit über eine spende zum
euch mit der er uns helfen dieses
projekt weiterzuführen den paypal link
dazu findet ihr in der beschreibung
unter dem video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]